this morning canada is allowing
americans to cross the border for the
first time since
march of 2020 if they are fully
vaccinated the u.s has not said when
canadians will be allowed to enter the
u.s however meg oliver is at niagara
falls a beautiful place right along the
border in western new york meg good
morning to you
beautiful indeed good morning tony
niagara falls new york is one of the
country's biggest tourist destinations
14 million visitors come here every year
to soak in the sights and to feel the
mist on their face
and this morning for the first time in a
year and a half they're also able to
cross over the border into canada
but for many canadian businesses they're
hoping it's not too late
this place is beautiful yeah we
encourage people to come and see
honestly yeah in niagara falls canada
the vast majority of the city's revenue
comes from the summer tourist season
which is almost over mayor jim diodati
says he grew frustrated
as month after month went by and the u.s
canada border
remained closed we're definitely going
in the right direction but i got to tell
you
for a long time it was a dim light at
the end of a very long tunnel
our business went to literally zero
doug burrell the ceo of niagara
hospitality hotels
says he was forced to lay off most of
his staff
due to the drop in business from
american visitors it just started to
really creep back for us and it's all
domestic so right now
it's it's a hundred mile radius toronto
coming here to niagara falls canada
right now that's it that's the market
starting today u.s travelers can cross
into canada if they show proof they are
fully vaccinated on an
app and have proof of a negative cova
test in the previous 72 hours
as long as people are vaccinated i think
that's great for 53 year-old mert
labounty the closed border
has meant an 18-month separation from
his girlfriend
tammy younkers the couple lives just 20
minutes apart
la bounty on the u.s side and yonkers in
canada
it is terrible for me it's i did i came
here
in hopes of starting a life with her and
starting a dream and it's very hard to
go every day every day without
having her in my life it got so bad
labonte started suffering from
depression
yonkers was able to come to the u.s in
july to check on him
but instead of a quick drive it took two
planes and two buses for a total
of 12 hours what kind of toll did this
take on your mental health
oh it's terrible i just i couldn't i
had no hopes of no energy to do anything
i just wanted to stay in one room
isolate and
just give up that's all i wanted to do
you wanted to give up yes
how emotional has this been for you
tammy he came here to be with me
so it just pains me all the time to know
that he's there
waiting for me but now their wait is
over
as of today la bounty can cross the
border to visit
what's it going to mean when you finally
get to go over
and hold on to tammy again i it's just
my whole world
you know it's just i i i feel like a
better person when i'm with her
tammy and mert now plan to live together
they just need to choose which side of
the border that will be
and an important note children 12 years
and younger are allowed into canada with
fully vaccinated parents but if you're
five and over you have to be tested on
the first day
and the eighth day vlad meg thank you
so much you definitely feel for
mert and tammy i i'm cheering them along
they should get married at niagara falls
on one of those little boats
old school stuff old school style in a
little boat like with the sea captain
yeah i've never been to niagara falls i
was teasing you and jerica's like i used
to work in buffalo
sorry she's a tour guide thank you again
meg beautiful live shot thank you very
much